good morning heck it's tuesday so i
recently read a book that is about um us
it's called narratives nerdfighters and
new media by jennifer burrick pierce
it's an academic work about online
community in general and nerdfighteria
in particular and of course i shouldn't
pretend to be objective about it i
shouldn't pretend to be objective about
anything actually but i loved it anyway
one of the things discussed in the book
is how nerdfighteria is often
constructed as a place both in the sense
that there are like maps of
nerdfighteria and in the sense that
there are rules and norms when you are
here that you understand may be
different from the rules and norms
elsewhere but in this imagined place
there is lots of real activity social
connections form art gets made memes are
memes is definitely going in the
background by the way anyway reading
this book i was reminded of that
marianne moore poem where she writes
that great poetry involves the creation
of imaginary gardens with real toads in
them like the place is imagined but the
people and the work inside of it are
very real so there's a chapter of the
book called connections commerce and
philanthropy that tackles some of the
complex questions around these sorts of
communities including like who owns
these real toads what are we going to do
about money how will the value that's
being created get captured and who will
capture it the easy answer is that the
creator owns it right like hank and i
own vlogbrothers videos and so whatever
money they make is our money but even if
we try to take that straightforward
approach it quickly gets complicated
because like youtube owns the
vlogbrothers channel and they are
certainly part of the value equation and
also you make the videos more valuable
by watching them but also because your
comments and your art and so on are not
just responses to the videos but also
expansions of them like take for example
pizza john do i own that because it's my
face taken from a screenshot of my video
or does valerie own it because they made
the design and when alice makes this who
owns it does the person who was
terrorized by dr never sneezer scrooge
own part of it now i think current laws
are a wholly insufficient guide on this
front but to be fair it's hard to make
laws about who owns what when so much
creative production is a remix of a
reblog of a retweet so instead of being
governed entirely by laws when it comes
to creating and capturing value
nerdfighteria is also governed in part
by norms it is uncool for instance to
repost something without credit and it's
governed in part by the terms of service
of private corporations which you know
tend to be a little bit rigged for
instance google receives just over 45 of
all revenue generated by nerdfighteria
within the youtube platform and that
does seem a little bit high to me the
other 55ish percent goes to hank and me
which also seems quite high because i
don't think that money belongs to hank
and me i think it belongs to
nerdfighteria which is why in the end
half of it goes to grants for
educational creators and the other half
goes to charity as burke pierce puts it
nerdfighteria's answer to this conundrum
in part is to recognize that money
accrues from creative work and to make a
gift of it to others but of course we
have to emphasize the in part in that
sentence right because hank and i are
only able to not make money from
vlogbrothers and dftba because we make
money other ways me from selling books
hank from having 12 million jobs and all
of that work is to varying degrees bound
up in nerdfighteria like yes i wrote
books before i made vlogbrothers videos
but i have certainly talked about my
books on vlogbrothers and they have
reached a wider audience as a result and
i have kept a lot of that book royalty
money so where's the line and where
should the line be those aren't
rhetorical questions by the way and i
would love your thoughts on them this
book helped me understand why i struggle
with those questions and also how over
the years our viewers have pushed us
toward considering issues around value
and ownership more carefully but reading
it i was also reminded of something else
even if nerdfighteria has generated tens
of millions of dollars for efforts aimed
at social good money is nowhere near the
most important thing that nerdfighteria
makes it makes joy it makes connection
and it makes opportunities for me to
better understand the universe and my
place in it and i wouldn't want to put a
price on any of that
hank i'll see you on friday